Wiggin is a long and winding lane from
the images portrayed by George Orwell in
his book the road to Wigan pier it's
where I was born where I grew up and
first became a journalist this is hey
Holl I had my wedding reception here all
my family were with me including my
granddad sir a former miner and lifelong
labour supporter the wicken I know has
only ever been a Labour stronghold
it hasn't been blue for more than a
hundred years now though it's once again
on the Conservative Party hit list and
this is why Wigan fits into the
Workington Man target group for the 2019
election according to the right leaning
think-tank onward working two-man are
working-class Rugby League town voters
over 45 white and who voted leave in the
2016 referendum I want out I've always
wanted out but I think I think it is to
do with breaks that most of the people
and say all the veteran community won't
have Corbin I think it well might be yes
I honestly do well I wouldn't but my
husband's from London and he always
brought story you gonna vote not a clue
at the moment well I won't say what the
allah' what Wigan Azhar is proud of
their roots and King coal runs through
their veins
this is Wigan Pier it's where coal that
was dug from the mines was brought to
the canal to be tipped up onto barges
for distribution via the Leeds Liverpool
canal mining was an incredibly tough
physically challenging profession I
remember as a young teenage reporter
here in Wigan covering stories of
desperate heartache one in particular
stays with me
an explosion at the Goulburn colliery
claimed the lives of 10 local men a
buildup of methane ignited and shot a
fireball along a tunnel 1,800 feet
underground it was 1979 and it rocked
the town communities came together to
support those left grieving five years
later the miner strikes or the town once
again rally around its mining community
with food parcels and financial support
for families brought down by a Thatcher
government but times have changed and
Tory is no longer a dirty word in my
hometown nevertheless it's going to be a
gigantic leap for voters well they
really switch sides and all things are
dirty very very very much why Logan's
been labor as long as I am 75 in a
couple of weeks and as long as I go by
it's always been LED and I don't think
it will ever change earnest here in
Wigan one of the first ever TV stories I
did was here at Uncle Joe's Minh Paul's
fresh-faced and with an affected accent
that had been perfected by reading see
facts into a ghetto blaster I thought I
was the bee's knees
we were all a bit younger then for
decades on John and his brother Anthony
is still running the show and having to
contend with the uncertainty of an
upcoming election and personally and
this is my own personal point of view is
that soon we can get it sorted out one
way or the other we can kick on and do
what we need to do and be great again I
think we've been very fortunate because
in times of hardship then people tend to
eat more sweets so a bit of a treat you
know so you don't buy your dishwasher in
a washing machine but we'll have a few
Uncle Joe's meatballs to suck much has
changed with the town and I have
undergone facelifts but the northern
grits and passion remain we're gonna
expect their politicians to keep their
word and for many that means brexit
pushing two-thirds voted to leave which
way will this Rugby League town vote in
December